los angeles county is one of the biggest
counties in the world actually alex
villanueva is the sheriff of l.a county
he has pledged not to enforce these
mandates because he doesn't want
citizens to die
the sheriff joins us tonight sheriff
thanks so much for coming on so we
talked to you
some time ago and you had this position
i know you've taken a lot of heat for it
tell us why you maintain this position
and what you think could happen if you
were to cave on this question
well the results are very obvious for
example i have a 20
increase in people that are putting to
retire early that's over 100 people
right there another 300 plus are filing
workers compensation claims that's a 22
increase i have 238 deputies and now
applying for out of county jobs that do
not have vaccine mandates and i have
1600 potential people that have 28 years
or more of service they could just walk
away and not lose a penny and not even
look back and that is a huge threat to
the department is already severely
understaffed but the board of
supervisors is just
they don't care apparently
so i've heard people say well you know
you lose a third of your firemen or 40
of your cops just like hire new people
just you know bring in i don't know temp
workers are you comfortable handing out
firearms and badges to people with no
experience
it takes me almost a year and a half to
replace an entry-level worker to replace
a veteran 30-year expert in whatever
capacity for example a homicide
investigator yeah those are decades that
it takes to replace someone like that
and you cannot quantify that with the
impact that is on public safety but
guarantee you homicides will go up a lot
of things are going to go up and
response time is going to get longer and
longer
your priorities are so exactly in the
right place i just have to ask you are
people
thanking you for taking a stand on this
well i got a lot of people that are
thanking me from across the political
spectrum except for one group the woke
left to somehow embrace this idea like
it's another cultural war to fight and
mandates but where is all the data that
supports mandates they're not looking at
hard science and hard data they're going
with well it feels good to have a
mandate
man
why didn't you run for governor
sheriff i appreciate your coming on
tonight sorry to embarrass you with that
great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else